[Music]
in the thirst is real news
that's like a sexy thing right that's oh
I thought it was like legit Oh like
dehydration yeah that's the problem
thirst is real when someone is really
really desperate at horn that's right
desperate could be desperate of
desperation submitted by where's the
lamb sauce what laughs oh that was the
reference and I don't know Michael B
Michael B Jordan buys a teen a new
retainer after she bit through it during
his shirtless Black Panther scene she's
wow humblebrag that's awesome what yes
it all started on tumblr I don't watch
the movie how do you say don't spoil it
for me I haven't seen the movie it's a
Marvel movie know how it's gonna be
every time yeah so this is a tumblr post
to start at all someone posted this
actually no it was okay yeah someone
posted this and then this person
retweeted it or reposted it and so it's
that the first one says get you a man
who can do both and it's Michael B
Jordan and looking like this and then
the person that reposted it said one of
my patients came in for an emergency
visit because she snapped the wire on
her retainer watching the movie when mbj
took his shirt off she clenched her
teeth so [ __ ] hard she snapped it
that is the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ]
everything
Oh this tiny 17 year old girl thirsting
so goddamn hard she burst steel horny
Wow dude you don't [ __ ] with those
people like the Twilight fans you
remember that Oh a couple years ago I
interviewed some people some of those
people and when Robert Pattinson and all
these cats got out of their limousine
like in front of us I was genuinely
afraid it was like like like you know
how they say [ __ ] strength yeah it was
like that kind of [ __ ] like they could
have taken down a barricade overwhelmed
every security team like it was it was
crazy
what's even crazy that if you see little
fans or any fanger
man they're like literally like in the
90s guys couldn't be open about their
personal relationships with other
females because they would find where
those girls live and write death notes
like send dead birds it's still right
now so they can't be open about any
other personal relationships because
they're afraid for like other people's
lives like when I went to this is this
kpop event in k-town
there was scroll on this escalator as
she sees the guy coming up I just see
her bawling she's going up that's why I
thank God Ricky Martin waited to tell
everyone he was gay
it would have been suicide oh for sure
100% yeah he was fine see when he was
coming up to and it was like a younger
audience for him man
I wonder what it's like to have people
like like you like that much I know
no idea no clue
we're unapproachable we're not as
attractive as them and we don't have an
appointment with our relationship and no
one care no people care and there was
nothing couldn't get into you that's
right that's what it is that would be
too it's like what does she do with this
book new knowledge it that's what I was
getting at that dress I see actually
love it
because I always like I don't care I
don't know I don't know you don't know
but I always like to say that there was
like oh yeah like like what do you got
man and I'm like well my dick has a
great personality she's very descriptive
yeah a little too much oh yeah awesome
you'll see in the film you understand
what you want me to tell you or no no no
no I'm watching wait what are you gonna
say what could you possibly say yes it's
a part of his character though okay yeah
that's like the buffest Shawn wins I've
ever seen his head is so tiny compared
to his body what happened and nobody
aired your joke what Shawn Wayans
you look like shanwa shanwa Marlene
Shawn wait
I know Marlin Damon what's his name
Hodge no my brain fall away like a white
chick Shawn Shawn Marlon doesn't watch
white chicks yeah wait Shawn is that
Shawn is his but on the Wayans brothers
the goofy one
really we all did I think Shawn's like
man that's my pup he came up first and
then we Kenan Kenan Kenan who's the
oldest see how no it's Damon
is it Kenan Damon Shawn and in Marlon I
think that's the order this would be the
best jeopardy questions she without the
LL Cool J show we met he was on the team
in did you I saw I see Marlon all the
time does he lose where I live oh we
audition in front of Kenan and it's
family and they let [ __ ] killed it I
went to a movie theater and Marlon was
going to see his own movie killed it
they laugh in the box the contract did
you get it no they passed the contract
and always got both of us it was written
by Hitler at the same time can you
believe he'll better
you killed it why didn't you do the
things we were gonna go on and they
wanted to shut down all yeah I said deny
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna let you shut
down JK feel were they gonna have you do
he did was going what was the show he
was in living color they're gonna bring
it back on air oh he was that I remember
that yep and then they kill they want it
they wanted but we we were the final
they were they wanted both of us we were
gonna seal off of Matt you actually work
because that show died because you
weren't on it oh we were on it we wanna
killed it do you think it aired we would
have brought it back in America they
said that the the talent today just
sucks I was over there and during the
audition I was peeing next in yeah we we
peed in the bathroom next to him and
said hi these how to pee at the same
time what the [ __ ] which I guess
nerve-wracking auditions are next to
which Martin was waiting for the Kenan
Kenan uh he went to pee that's pretty
close pee like every five minutes also
nervous he's vegan and I was stretching
in the way you said Shawn out of my mind
he next - Shawn Wayans
we got it looks like this guy wrote yes
so anyway this is the scene that made
her clench her jaw so hard so then the
girl Sophia she found this tumblr post
and she posted it on Twitter she said
wait that girl is me that is my
orthodontist tumblr this is a post about
me I'm going to kill myself
we're outing yourself out yeah why would
you nobody even knew it [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out this is literally my orthodontist
and he's the chillest person I have ever
met that's tight even though he exposed
me on the Internet it's bad you exposed
yourself oh yeah yeah of course and this
is the orthodontist he brought it
doesn't write like them yeah and then
Michael B Jordan tweeted at her said
since I feel partly responsible for
breaking Area Tanner's let me know if I
can replace them I feel like she read
this and fell down the stairs after
that's so funny my orthodontist outed me
out it's me this is my address this is
where I live this is what I look like I
know they love it oh my god so funny
that's pretty dumb to imagine like that
was her reaction and then he's actually
tweeting at her that is really cool yeah
it's also a little bit embarrassing
because he's paying for your broken
retainers I don't care what's happening
if I'm in contact with like my my name
is crush yeah he got he got yoked up
though he got [ __ ] jack what if it
was like like she's soaked her painting
so hard like he's like yeah I'll replace
those pants that's basically what this
is yeah and then the movie theater
establishments like hey can you replace
to see cuz the things [ __ ]
rig it out like it's into like one of
those big clear cups during double dare
more that teenage girls have such
superhuman strength and determination I
think we should create like a Navy SEALs
just for teenage girls and then it's
just they have to be motivated properly
so like they could be crazy determined
and all that stuff if it's like a k-pop
star or the favorite celeb dude if we
brainwashed these little girls I'm with
you like sad I'm in a room and convince
them that these Isis leaders look like
[ __ ] boy teen star don't find them those
guys would be dead in hours hours yeah
cuz they'll get on any plane go to these
places they'll go track them down and
kill them yeah kill them with love
you're gonna say like the leader of Isis
has a direct connection to Justin Bieber
and if you could get to him that's a you
could hang out with just although Justin
Bieber's the old news now that's true
it's gotta be me it's gotta be new [ __ ]
Michael B Jordan wife's got two minutes
found him that's it he's right there
because they stop these people online
you know what right they know they also
follow the people that are near them
like the entire truth right the posses
get all all get followers yeah and then
they come in droves - that's like how do
they know cuz like I saw I don't know I
saw this random TMZ video Bill Murray
gettin asked a question he's signing
autographs like how do they know Bill
Murray's at some Italian restaurant
publicist called paparazzi - for that
reason give a what dub Murray wouldn't
publish would do that maybe maybe they
just know where to hang out yeah I met a
paparazzi guy and he that's his like
career like he just makes money just
taking pictures and it was pretty shitty
but he says that there's just local
places that you know these guys frequent
or whatever yeah yeah but there's a
tip-off - he's like it's it's a win-win
situation sometime because people that
are kind of falling off they want
publicity because they're gonna be
promoting this new movie or whatever so
they want to be back in the limelight
and then they tip off the paparazzi
see but some of these pictures man
they're crazy they'll go for like 20
grand or something just wide oh yeah if
they're like hot in the news I bet yeah
like I remember when Robin Williams had
just gotten back on the wagon or all he
fell off the wagon mhm
like the pictures of him coming out of
UCB where I was working at the time I
could just come out and I bet you those
were like way more than yeah he's sad so
they take pictures to see it was cool we
were all like holy [ __ ] Robin Williams
is here like I was I was at the theater
that know that pass the [ __ ] out and he
was like doing improv on stage and
everybody and then the next day I look
at the news and it's like Robin Williams
check back into rehab so I just like
that night he went on a bender
that's my teenage girl moment like if I
see [ __ ] like that I'll be like yeah
Robin Williams I mean he's like iconic
oh he's so influential to like I think
anybody already that like yeah dude
[ __ ] mrs. Doubtfire I love that [ __ ]
and he was a sweetie man he's nice
[Music]
[Music]